slide one shows the testing capacity and
the number of new cases the the slide
the top chart in the slide shows the
number of tests and that number of tests
as of the second of June was a hundred
and thirty five thousand six hundred and
forty three this is different to testing
capacity which stands at just over two
hundred thousand and as I said yesterday
this demonstrates that there is spare
capacity in testing and so if you have
symptoms of corona virus that's a fever
or a new dry cough or a change in your
sense of taste or smell then please do
go and get a test from NHS UK forward
slash coronavirus or by phoning one one
nine it's incredibly important that we
can trace the virus by ensuring that
anybody with symptoms has a test and of
course we're rolling out testing across
care homes and making sure that staff in
hospitals get the opportunity to be
tested as well and the bottom a chart on
the slide shows the number of confirmed
cases and this is one thousand six
hundred and thirteen as of again the
second of June and brings the total of
number of cases confirmed in the UK to
two hundred and seventy seven thousand
nine hundred and eighty five and
although the 1613 figure is slightly
higher than yesterday we can see that
the seven-day rolling average continues
to fall second slide please the data
from hospitals show that those new
admissions to hospitals in England has
fallen to four hundred and thirty six
this is down from four hundred and
seventy one on the 24th of May so just
over a week ago and down from a high of
3121 on the second of April this figure
of four
thirty-six admissions to hospitals in
England with kovat 19 is the lowest
figure since the 20th of March and it
demonstrates once again that we are
making progress against this disease
again as yesterday then the proportion
of mechanical ventilators ventilated
beds that are occupied by patients with
corona corona virus remains at 9%
next slide please thank you and just
like yesterday the number of people in
hospital continues to fall seven
thousand six hundred and seven are now
in hospital with corona virus and that
is falling in broadly falling in each
part of the country but for a little bit
of day-to-day movement in some of the
areas for instance as you can see right
at the end of the chart for the
Northeast and Yorkshire but we keep that
very closely under review but the
overriding trend as you can see is
downwards the next slide is the number
of deaths and sadly on the on the second
of June yesterday 324 deaths with corona
virus were recorded taking the total to
thirty nine thousand three hundred and
sixty nine and we mourn each one of
these and we try to keep these data as
accurate as possible including where we
find in in the past those the in some
cases there are deaths where we discover
that there has been a connection to
corona virus and we add those into those
those data so we can see that the again
the trend is broadly down but there is
still some way to go and after the
weekend effect which we've seen each
weekend in terms of the number of deaths
recorded because these this is according
to the date these have recorded we've
seen that rise on a on most Mondays and
and sadly the figure is 324 today
next slide final slide please and the
the final slide reports on data from the
Office for National Statistics which was
reported this morning and reported a
total of forty eight thousand one
hundred and six deaths in the UK where
kovat 19 was mentioned on the death
certificate and you can see that this
again this number is falling the top
chart in it shows those those data and
shows where we were on the recorded
daily deaths data for the period that
correspond 'add to these data coming
from the ons on the bottom chart we can
see the place of occurrence of those
deaths and you can see that both the
number of deaths and the proportion of
deaths that are in care homes both of
those are falling twenty-seven point
three percent of deaths occurred in care
homes in the latest ons data to the week
beginning the week of the may the 22nd
bringing the proportion overall of
deaths in care homes down to thirty two
point five percent we we don't capture
in these charts but we do capture in a
report published by public health
England today further data some of which
are much more troubling and the PhD
investigation into the way in which the
virus targets people unequally and
disproportionately has been put on the
website and this is a particularly
timely publication because right across
the world people are angry about racial
injustice and I get that black lives
matter and I want to say this to
everyone who works in the NHS and in
social care I value the contribution
that you make everybody equally and I
want to say it right across society too
I want to thank you and I want you to
know that our whole country cares about
your well-being and I value too
those who come to our country to work in
the NHS and in social care and I love
that this country is one of the most
welcoming and tolerant and diverse that
goes for the whole country and it goes
especially for the health and care
system as I said in the House of Commons
earlier pH ease investigation found that
age is the biggest risk factor for
coronavirus next gender living in a city
is a risk and being black or from a
minority ethnic background is also a
significant risk factor there is much
more work to do to understand what's
driving these disparities and how the
different risk factors interact and we
are absolutely determined to get to the
bottom of this and find ways of closing
that gap and I'm delighted that cami bad
knock the Minister for equalities will
be taking this work forward working with
Phe and many others we value the
contribution from everyone to fighting
this virus everyone has a contribution
to make